this is a production of Cornell
University
hi this is Frank Rossi for the Cornell
turfgrass video log this week we're
talking about mowing now in the
springtime you get that surge of growth
because we know about sixty to seventy
percent of all the clippings produced
for the entire season are produced in
the first six weeks of the growing
season so it's very typical then we're
going to mow more in the spring now for
those of you striving for a more
sustainable approach to your lawn maybe
you're going to cut back on mowing a
little bit and so what happens is you're
left to have to cut the grass when it's
really high now of course we don't want
clippings clumping up everywhere is that
can be a problem from a light shading of
the turf so it might be worthwhile to
just sort of scratch scratch them around
set the mower as high as you can try to
mow slowly so that you're distributing
the clippings and most importantly make
sure you're mowing when it's dry that
will allow for the clippings to disperse
and in the end you may find if you just
skip one mowing per month you're cutting
your mowing 25% for the entire year and
that can have a real benefit on fuel
expenses as well as improving the carbon
emissions in the environment thanks for
joining me for the Cornell turfgrass
video log this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at
cornell.edu